a community in Cameroon is going green  in the West African country the  population is growing by 2.5% a year  this leads to severe environmental  problems like deforestation pollution  and loss of biodiversity Joshua khong  khong co wanted to try something new in  buffered he founded cameroons first eco  village houses here are built with local  materials like stones mud bricks and  wood the stoves are designed to use less  firewood to grow their food villagers  employ permaculture techniques like  intercropping and fertilizing with  manure  joshua khong khong co also plants fruit  trees and medicinal trees which one day  could be a source of income if it works  out the ecovillage could show that  population growth and an intact  environment don't have to be a  contradiction do you like that if you're  also doing your bit tell us about it  visit our website or send us a tweet  hashtag doing your bit we share your  stories